[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone we will be starting the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello once again everyone please take
your seats we're about to begin
please take your seats everyone please
take your seats everyone please be
seated please take your seats were about
to begin a live show a live show is
about to begin
everyone we're about to start live show
in 30 seconds make that 10 make that
three hello everyone and welcome to the
closing ceremony of the st. Louis rapid
in blitz and the opening ceremony of the
Sinquefield Cup I'm Maurice Ashley and
I'm happy to be here at the world chess
Hall of Fame quite prestigious
institution as we close and kick off
these marvellous events it's been a
wonderful season so far of chess and a
great summer of chess has begun has one
event has concluded another about to
begin I would like to thank Shannon
Bailey of the world chess Hall of Fame
and her wonderful staff they do a
fabulous job thank you so much Shannon
for hosting this event of course none of
this would be possible without the
generosity of two amazing people we
would very much like to thank dr. Jeanne
fixing field and Rex Sinquefield for all
you do for chess a visionary who is
always here in spirit and we hope to see
him physically here at some point during
the summer he is the one who had the
grand vision for the grand chest or not
here today but watching somewhere maybe
I think far off in Croatia in his summer
home enjoying the beach Gary thank you
very much Gary Kasparov is a great team
who heads the board off the grand chess
or Michael Khodorkovsky Graham Jorgenson
and Tony rich without them their
tireless efforts during the year none of
this happens they're great designs is
what makes the chest or the grand chest
or as exciting as it is please thank
them as well
and none of this happens without the big
bucks from the sponsors so we'd like to
thank our sponsors
Jill Beth Hauser with Colliers
International Vivendi and the sponsors
in Abidjan and Paris along with game
plan in India and the local sponsors in
Croatia a big hand please
we need them to up the ante next year
make it a couple of million and he
wasn't here for the opening ceremony
which was really strange for the st.
Louis wrap it was really really strange
never see that happen but he's back the
big dog the executive director Tony Rich
thank you thank you all and I can't
believe that I actually missed an
opening ceremony or a closing ceremony
that was my very first one that I have
but I'm really happy to be here with you
all tonight I'd like to begin by
thanking all of the players those of you
that participated in the rabbit and
blitz tournament it was exciting there
was blood across the board every single
game every single round and I know all
of your fans around the world really
enjoyed it I'd also like to thank my
staff at the Chess Club you know it
really does take a team of folks lots
and lots of individual people each doing
their own individual roles as best as
they can in order to put on an amazing
event like this so it wouldn't have been
possible without my great team at the
Chess Club a round of applause for them
[Applause]
and I just like to echo it Marie said as
well Shannon Bailey is my counterpart
here at the hall of fame and her team
does an amazing job you know I never
really thought I was very into art until
the world chess Hall of Fame open and it
kind of opened my eyes to what art could
be especially as it relates to chess so
an amazing institution I've done a
pretty good job of keeping my speeches
short and sweet and I will do just that
so now it's my pleasure to introduce to
you the godmother of chess jeanne singh
field yes you know why he wasn't here
right he was getting the how do you
pronounce that
Colton now ski award gold Colts and s
keyword for the st. Louis chess club so
thank you he actually went to pick up my
award hey it's very nice to see you all
and all of you great players so I always
get to introduce Rex today we're just
gonna have a little game you know over
the years you see me we compete a little
bit he does this and I do the little
stuff so I know you guys have been
waiting the new numbers for the boys
who've learned and girls now who have
learned chess in the United States the
chest merit badge is 250,000
[Applause]
so and I had the honor of publishing my
first chest booklet all 12 pages
learning to read and write chest and I
have you know that I have players who
have inadvertently agreed to translate
this into so far we have Spanish French
Russian Hebrew Farsi Hindu Armenian so
we're working on Norwegian so like I
said we're gonna teach everybody to play
chess okay start with a little kids but
then I get to talk about the best
players in the world right here are the
best players in the world so let's give
them a hand
okay and so there was the guy with all
the visionary my husband remember it's a
joke I haven't told it a long time so I
can tell it again when he started
playing chess years ago I said to myself
how expensive could it be so the
Godfather of chess marian's later all
things are relative well thank you
Jeannie first of all I want to welcome
the players that have just arrived this
is definitely my favorite month of the
year in favor of time hosting all these
incredibly great players in the city of
st. Louis and I do suffer some
homesickness
in French smile to payee that's far out
Mira she understands when the players
leave why are you laughing I said it
perfectly so let's welcome all these
great players once again thank you and
of course we especially want to
recognize Grand Master Lanier Dominguez
not only did he change his Federation
from Cuba to the United States earlier
this year but he also officially moved
to st. Louis and he now calls st. Louis
home and
and I talked to the Board of Aldermen
and they said they're going to
officially change the official language
of st. Louis from English to Spanish
thank all of our tremendous commentary
teams that would just send this this
event all over the world
and of course our online team is great
grandmasters Yasir Sara Juan Maurice
Ashley and Jennifer Shahade II the
Russian team mural and L Mira and and I
hope I'm forgiven for not using your
entire name but your names are too
difficult and complicated for a simple
guy like me and the kingside we have
Christian shahrullah and Alejandro
Ramirez respectively the coaches of the
University of Missouri chess team and
the st. Louis University chess team and
the staff of the Chess Club starting
with joy a joy Bray is amazing fact at
night when I go out and I see the moon I
go I think joy Bray hung that moon in
this guy that's how accomplished she is
so and everybody with Tony the executive
director of the club Shannon the chief
curator here and everything you do all
the events you put on they're just
they're just unbelievable and I used to
say we have seven art museums in st.
Louis but I realize that's wrong with
this we have eight so we have to
recognize that and I want to thank all
the staff people who do all this great
work behind the scenes
Tammy hide and key take it silverback
Studios Erik Mosul and Randy Sinquefield
whoo he's handsome intelligent we're
trying to figure out who his father is
and these people do such a great job for
the show and the production throughout
the year the livestreams and Ben Simon
and Isaac France were handling
production of the Russian commentary and
they make all these broadcasts and live
show an incredible success and I do say
we reach more people and more online
viewers in 12 days I'm gonna make this
assertion I think it's true we reach
more people online in 12 days than the
st. Louis Cardinals do in an entire
season
I may get challenged on that but you
know I our numbers are awfully big when
you see how many people we reach it's
incredible
we're over 200 countries st. Louis
Cardinals are lucky to get an audience
outside the state of Missouri but there
are my favorite team so I can't be too
harsh and then when we had the start at
the rapid or blitz ceremony we unveiled
the new tables with somebody's staff
called the sing field tables which is
ridiculous they're the Nate Cohen tables
and I was inspired by the tables that we
have from Havana in 1966 which are
property of the world chess Hall of Fame
and I thought Cathy's are beautiful
tables they're got to be so comfortable
for the players and so we had Nate Cohen
an incredibly talented woodworker and he
came up with a beautiful hybrid and I
appreciate the announcers mentioning on
the air how beautiful they appeared on
the air they really do so now we just
have to joy and I have had a running
debate and discussion and disagreement
about what chairs would be appropriate
for the Grand Master's and you Grand
Master's can help me because I think you
should have and Bobby Fischer insisted
on this by the way chairs that rock roll
and swivel I think that would be the
most comfortable for you so when you
leave here just tell joy we want Rex's
idea for chairs let's get together Sam a
little you know cabal here so what so in
the games in the st. Louis rapid and
blitz were really incredible exciting
all of them as Tony said all the blood I
know it sounds awful that we revel in
that but we do and so that was wonderful
I now look forward to watching what I
think is the best event of a year the
Sinquefield Cup watching these great
players go at it again thank you all so
much
Thank You X we might have to do some
fact checking on some parts of your
speech Rex aye I think so all right well
we comes a time where we introduce the
players we know these players but they
certainly deserve their own introduction
so I will go around the room and remind
of us all the players who played in the
st. Louis rapid inlets and the new ones
who have joined us for the sing field
Cup I will start on this end first of
all from the USA by way of Cuba linear
Dominguez from Azerbaijan chakra
marmiteiros from the United States
Fabiano Caruana
from friends Maxime of uh Sheila Graham
from India Vishwanath on Iran from the
Netherlands Netherlands that is a nice
giri from the United States see Cairo
dr. moura from the United States Wesley
Seoul from Russia young upon the Chi
from Russia Sergey Kuryakin from China
ding Lorraine from Armenia Levon Aronian
from China
you young ye and from Norway the world
champion Magnus Carlsen
[Applause]
as has been said before the st. Louis
rapid ability was simply an incredible
event very exciting we didn't know until
the very end who was going to win
it's the kind of event we commentators
love the fans love the players don't
like so much but it was very very
exciting but we could only have a few
winners so first of all I'd like for the
second-place winners to stand they all
had incredible events they were you
young Yi ding Lauren and maxium vos
Sheela grave
please stand but there could only be one
winner he's done it before
he did it two years ago in 2017 so he
must love something about st. Louis and
something about the st. Louis rapid and
blitz the winner of the 2019 st. Louis
rapid in blitz from Armenia Levon
Aronian Levon will get his cup from
Jeanne and Rex and take some Beauty
shots before saying a few words or we
get the official photograph Levon won by
a half a point in this event it was a
very tight event throughout but he
showed his tenacity at the very end it
was very difficult as you know but he
was able to win that Tony I believe
you're supposed to come up and take a
photo also
and to eat a big challenge to wait and
get in such a formidable field and if
you may please sit and LaVon could we
get a few words from you as the others
sit down LaVon thank you guys for being
here and for the kind words
it was truly exciting event I love
playing in city of San Louis and where
we're as chess players were proud to be
chess players and we're loved and that's
thanks mainly to the single family so
thankful and to the interest that due to
their efforts it has been generated by
by the United States so the event was
very interesting I can say that at some
point it felt like you know this running
where you have to put the dinosaur suit
so everybody was falling and but it was
a lot of excitement and I can say I was
lucky in a way to win the tournament
because there was such a chase but as my
father loves to put well whenever I was
little they would say oh your son just
got lucky if I would say of course he's
lucky
I mean he's smarter than your children
[Laughter]
not meaning to disrespect anybody but I
I want to say it's it's a it's a good
warm-up for the main event and I'm very
excited once again to try and to compete
against the best in the world so I'd
like to thank everybody who are here
today and who are watching online and
who follow the upcoming tournament I
would like to thank the sinful family
also thank my wife and my parents and my
sister
everybody has been watching so thank you
once again grandmaster Levon Aronian all
right well that event has concluded and
another one begins five new players
enter into the fray they have been
sitting watching all the fights that
have been going on so I'd like to start
with them to ask the opening question
for this brief press conference I'm
gonna start in the end with Grandmaster
a nice Giri
if you may hand him the microphone and
each the question for you five will be
this one given that you didn't have an
opportunity to play in this event do you
think that was a positive or a negative
for you and how does it affect your
chances going into the Sinquefield Cup
well I've seen the games the event and
looking at how poor everybody played I
think I would have played I would have
played even poorer so I think for me
it's good I skipped that one yeah for
sure I think it couldn't have gotten
worse than it is now so it's fine yeah I
think I would agree with I mean I think
everybody has played a lot of chess and
some games were quite a few bad blunders
and based on my own experience in Paris
where I made more blunders and I'd like
to remember I think it's certainly a
good thing I didn't play because I think
I also probably would have lost a lot of
points like everybody else
sorry I didn't finish the question
though in terms of chances I don't think
it changed the whole locks classical is
much slower and everybody won't make as
many blunders so I don't think it
matters that much because Magnus was
there
oh no I feel someone took Magnus
identity during the dinner like his twin
brother played for him but yeah I'm also
glad to have three and a half weeks of
breath well what if like Shaq just kept
on playing yeah yeah yeah well the batch
was very fierce I mean it was really fun
to watch even be in between fights I was
like especially yesterday he was landing
in Detroit you know watching couple of
games and then I kept flying to st.
Louis actually and you know in Abidjan I
played against Westley and they
blundered mate in one at some point and
he didn't see it and probably now I know
that I'm not only the only person who
blunders machen one even among the best
one yes sir that's really that's really
for me sir
I'm not ashamed anymore and considering
the chances well just no idea I almost
feel bad they're criticizing these guys
after the first four but I have to say
watching them play chess I was relieved
not to be playing because it it looked
like a cauldron out there the lead was
flipping back and forth and I think it
would have been 2/10 and I hope the rest
that I got will be helpful for my own
tournament all right those are the five
we will now go to the seven who will be
playing in the same field cup the
remaining seven I joined them so we'll
start with you Maxime the microphones
closest given that you did play in the
st. Louis wrapping the Blitz how do you
feel about having played and its chances
the chances it gives you to do well here
in the same field
it was a fun tournament I'm trying to
forget about some some of the events
that transpired some of my games
but yeah in general I don't think it
matters so much I mean going into the
same field cup I don't think that any of
us will do better or worse because we we
played in the web it
oh yeah same questions same Oh what can
I say about my face I actually think it
was summarized best by Grandmaster many
years ago I think it was after the game
against Hikaru actually which he
seriously miss played and he said if I
don't kill myself tonight all of a
thousand years I'm still here so I'm
actually looking forward to the next one
with confidence Chuck very interesting
tournament very good games interesting
games too many mistakes it's very good I
mean it's interesting for tournament for
just lovers okay I lost every day
minimum seven game six games it's
something new for me I good first time
lost pace I mean I hope again I will
back and maybe next year we'll play
maybe I will lost not five six two two
three good thank you sorry linear next
year we hope to see you in the same
magnets the same question to you
apparently I didn't
but if I were to speak for my evil twin
brother then and he were to play the
single cup he would probably not be so
so pleased with his results but he would
he would look forward to to the future
and he's been pretty good at the in the
past of living the past behind and
focusing on the future so I think he
would do the same this time we look
forward to seeing you sorry you yummy
also hoping to come next time actually
I'll let you go last so that's it Sergey
well I I was actually very happy to win
this and Lewis bliss tournament for the
second time but but but unfortunately
the tournament doesn't exist because
it's it's reggaeton bliss so basically
very poorly in repeat and much better in
breeze maybe not to the end but but
anyway it was much better and well I
hope that I I found I realized that I
can play in in repeat and I hope okay my
my tournament and classic would be more
like in Greece ding Lorraine so chest
part I was very pleased with my
performance but since we have been
aboard for some so long and will stay
here for another two weeks I started to
worry about the rise I bring here
rice yes we're in Boise enough do you
think we could get dinner in some rice
we know some people and how does this
the rice notwithstanding how does this
affect your chances to win this thing
field cut supermarkets I leave following
that LaVon I will leave the last
question to you your feeling about
having played I guess it's sort of
obvious but how does that affect your
chances to win this thing field yeah
generally playing blades prior to to the
main event is a good thing and and if
you manage to win it it's even better so
yeah I think as Rex and Jenny told me
there was nobody who want plates in the
classical in the same year so I think
I'm in a pretty good position I look
forward to the main event indeed Bravo
thank you once again the players for
responding candidly and now we're going
to get the person who keeps everyone in
line International arbiter Chris Byrd
Thank You Maurice first of all I would
like to I cannot do all the work by
myself so I'd like to introduce my two
assistant arbiters I will have one of
them again for the sink filled cup and
and also we we had one both of them for
the Rapidan blitz so Karen Panik and
Enrique waiter thank you very much and
also on behalf of myself and the
arbiters I would like to thank the st.
Louis chess club and the Grantchester
for inviting us to be a part of these
events we were chess fans as well and
it's very much privilege to to be
invited so thank you I've been asked to
say a little bit about the Sinquefield
Cup and what's gonna be happening this
year so the Sinquefield Cup this year
will be a twelve player round-robin so
starting on Saturday and over the next
12 days as we'll have a rest in between
the players will play one round a day
starting at 1:00 p.m. Central at a time
control of game in one hundred and
thirty minutes with a 30 second delay
and all players will play everybody else
once in a round-robin and hopefully by
the end of that we'll have a soul winner
but if not we will we will head to
playoffs so you know look forward to all
the action over the next couple of weeks
I would like to ask Tony to please come
up and grab the mic from Maurice real
quickly so I am going to announce the
pairings for round 1 and invite the two
players that will be playing each other
to come up and to let collect a small
gift that Tony will explain so I okay so
the chess sets that the players are
using when they compete in the st. Louis
rapid blitz and in the sink filled cup
we're actually Rex's idea they were his
inspiration house of Staunton in Frank
camerata
make beautiful chess sets really some of
the best that I've ever
and in fact they had one that was called
the Imperial collector series it was an
oversized chess set very elegant very
fine detail to a trek saw that and said
you know we should produce a set
something kind of like this to be able
to use during these major events instead
of the default dgt pieces which if
you've seen them before they look kind
of like a Picasso painting very you know
so frank Cammarata actually designed
what is the Sinquefield set this is a
replica of the king obviously it too is
oversized compared to what they play on
but the Sinquefield set is quite
possibly the most beautiful chess set
that I've ever seen if you have the
opportunity you should stop by the club
during the tournament and actually take
a look at all these pieces while the
players are moving in fact this King
might look very familiar because you saw
it when you walk in the front door this
is the same King that is the world's
largest chess piece just about 19 and a
half feet smaller
all right so Chris if you want to call
out the pairings we can have the players
come up and accept their gifts
absolutely so the pairings we don't have
to do a drawing of lots the pairings
were determined by the Croatia pairings
and so the players will now play with
the alternate colors from the pairings
from that round and I don't think we
could have come up with a much more
mouth-watering set of pairings if I
hand-picked them myself so the first
parent I'd like to welcome up to come
and collect their pieces Magnus Carlsen
will have the white pieces against a
niche kiri
and the next set of pairings I would
like to welcome up since you just won
the rapid and blitz I'd like to welcome
up Levon Aronian who will have the white
police's against Maxime Vasya grav and
another mouth-watering Perrin I'd like
to welcome up with the white pieces he
Cara Nakamura and with the black pieces
Fabiano Carolina
and the next couple I would like to
welcome up Tingler ring will have the
white pieces against Wesley sir
after that I would like to welcome up
Janna pom Miyaichi who will have the
white pieces against Miss wanna phone
and
and last but not least that should leave
us sega kayaking with the white pieces
against Shukria mama gerald that's it
back to you maurice thank you so much
Chris well that's it we have the
pairings the battle is about to be
joined we will have our show tomorrow
beginning at 12:50 Central Time the
games will begin at 1:00 there'll be
commentary I mean two days from now
excuse me we get a day off tomorrow
forgive me that's good we get a day off
two days from now
please join us 1250 Central Time and one
o'clock will be the official start of
the game will have live commentary in
Russian we will have live commentary the
kingside diner will have our production
assistant bar Kobe and helping us also
want to thank dr. Bob Romney on who was
a grand chest tour journalist it'll be a
ton of fun we all look forward to a
thank you very much for joining us
everyone and have a great night
[Music]
you